اعتادت يانا البالغة من العمر ثماني سنوات على الذهاب إلى
فصل الجمباز ستة أيام في الأسبوع في
أوديسا بأوكرانيا ،
وهي الآن تمارس هنا مركزًا للاجئين
في وارسو بولندا ، هل تعلم لماذا
قررت والدتك أن الوقت قد حان لكي لا تسير على
ما
يرام بسبب حدوث انفجارات  هناك
وأشياء من هذا القبيل
هل سمعت انفجارات هل رأيت
أي حرب
غادرت أوكرانيا مع شقيقها
ووالدتها لودميلا كانت الرحلة صعبة للغاية
لأننا قررنا الذهاب إلى هناك عبر مولدوفا
عبر رومانيا
عبر المجر وعبر
سلوفينيا سلوفينيا ثم  بولاند
جانا تجلس على طاولة مليئة
بالإمدادات المتبرع بها وتذهب إلى المدرسة عن بعد على
هاتفها في منتصف
مركز وارسو للاجئين وهي بخير
تقول نعم
لودميلا بوتز ليست متأكدة تمامًا
من صدمتها حتى هنا في
كل مرة
عندما أسمع  هناك بعض الأصوات
وعندما تحلق الطائرة
أخشى أن كرم بولندا
تجاه تدفق اللاجئين في أوكرانيا في مأوى اللاجئين ، الطعام ،
لوازم الأطفال موثق جيدًا ، أقل
شهرة هو التركيز على  ما لا يمكنك
رؤيته هو الصحة العقلية لمعظم النساء
والأطفال الذين يعبرون الحدود ،
لقد قمت بإعادة توجيه الكثير من
الأطباء النفسيين إلى
الأوكرانيين ، نعم ، قال
عمدة وارسو رافال تروسكوفسكي ، إن
الاعتناء بجروح الأوكرانية العاطفية
هو
أسس مهمة قم بإسقاط المنشورات التي تشجع
اللاجئين الأوكرانيين على ذلك.  البحث عن المشورة
لهؤلاء الأطفال يتمتعون بمرونة لا تصدق ولكنك
لا تعرف أبدًا أنك تعرف
ما هو تحت السطح ولكن لم
يمض وقت طويل حتى قال الناس نوعًا
ما تمتص الأمر ،
لكن هذا لم
يعد مكاننا في المجتمع بعد الآن  لا ، أعني
عندما ترى ما يحدث في
أوكرانيا على وجه الخصوص ، كيف كانت هذه الحرب شرسة
وكل الفظائع التي ارتكبها
الجنود الروس ، أعني أن هؤلاء الأطفال يشاهدون التلفاز كما
تعلمون أنهم يرون ذلك
في هذه الجلسة الجماعية ،
أخصائي الصحة العقلية للمرأة الأوكرانية  هي
لاجئة زميلة في دائرة النساء كما
يسمونها العواطف المدفونة
تطفو على السطح
بينما الأمهات ر  نهاية لصحتهم العقلية ،
أطفالهم في
رعاية نهارية مؤقتة على الجانب الآخر من الغرفة ،
تشعر يانا الصغيرة بسعادة غامرة بالألعاب
والأشخاص الجدد الذين يلعبون مع الشباب بما يكفي
لعدم معرفة الكثير
من أختها الكبرى أنطونينا تعرف أكثر من ذلك بكثير
خبرة أكثر من  يجب على أي طفل يبلغ من العمر ثماني سنوات
أنطونينا ، لماذا أنت هنا في
بولندا
بسبب الحرب
لأنني لا أعرف أن
لدى بوتين شيئًا ما في رأسه
يتبين أنه ليس كل الكبار يتخذون قرارات جيدة ، أليس
كذلك عندما يتعلق الأمر بطرح
نعم للأفضل  اعتني ببناتها
أمهاتهم تعتني بنفسها في
جلسة العلاج هذه
مع أشخاص متشابهين في التفكير ، فمن الأسهل
التحدث إلى أنهم يفهمونك لماذا
تريد إجراء هذه الجلسات
عندما نتحدث إلى نساء أخريات نسمع أن
لدينا نفس المشاكل و  نرى
موقفنا من
مسافة ، وأبرز الصدمة هي أن النساء
لا يرين غدًا لأنهن غير
متأكدات من أنهن خائفات وخائفات
لأنهن لا يشعرن بالحماية في أي مكان ومن
المهم أن ننقل لهن ذلك.
نحن غدًا
أما اليوم فإن رؤية أطفالهم
يلعبون مبتسمين يضحكون فهذا يساعدهم على
الذهاب إلى الغد دانا باش سي إن وارسو
بولندا